تفاجا السكان اثناء الليل بصاروخ روسي سقط
على هذا المبنى في وسط المدينه
تحت الانقاض وجد رجال الانقاذ اول ضحيه
لكن هناك المزيد يحاولون الان البحث عن
ناجين تم تدمير المبنى بالكامل ولحقت
اضرار بثمانيه مباني اخرى مجاوره في
البدايه سمعت صوت صفير ثم بدا كل شيء
بالاهتزاز على تويتر ادان رئيس الاوكراني
الهجوم فولودي مرزيلنسكي يقر اليوم بان
الوضع يزداد تعقيدا في شرق البلاد كرامات
ضرب الارهابيون الروسي المدينه بصاروخ
باليستين ادى الى وقوع اصابات بين
المدنيين بعض الناس ما زالوا تحت الانقاض
لا هدف لهم سوى الرعب ان السبيل الوحيد
لوقف الارهاب الروسي هو الحاق الهزيمه به
بواسطه الدبابات والطائرات المقاتله
والصواريخ بعيده المدى
تقع كراماتورسك في المنطقه الشرقيه من
دونيتسك التي يسيطر الانفصاليون المدعومون
من روسيا على اجزاء منها منذ عام 2014
وفقا لكيف تتجهز موسكو لهجوم جديده على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه خلال الاسابيع القليله
المقبله اذ يتقدم الجيش الروسي على الارض
بشكل خاص في شمال وجنوب بخموت المدينه
الاستراتيجيه في الدومباز والتي اصبحت
الهدف الرئيسيه لروسيا في الاشهر الاخيره